je croise le trauma mans est arrivé
ça va être une fois les horribles
[Applaudissements]
ouais
c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
qui veut un self i uta qlg toute ta vie
tatoué sur mon corps ouais
dans toute l'histoire des combats de
monstres
aucun champion n'a égalé tentaculaire le
monde entier s'interroge y at il un
challenger qui arrache la motivation et
la discipline pour devenir le prochain
champion
je crois que ça suffit pour aujourd'hui
je sais que steve on n'a pas l'air comme
ça mais il ya un véritable champion à
lui il en a mangé un merci beaucoup
ça fait plaisir
il va sérieusement falloir travailler ta
force et ont envie rentrer heureusement
j'ai la solution quoi
oui alors non ça va pas être possible
[Musique]
on essaye encore
mais on est mal oh c'est un cauchemar